former New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg is already revealing a
willingness to break from the Democratic
pack as he takes a step to run for
president on Friday his advisor said
Bloomberg plans to skip campaigning in
the first four states to vote and focus
initially on the 15 states participating
in Super Tuesday on March the 3rd this
is the billionaire qualified to get on
the ballot in one of those Super Tuesday
states Alabama here's ed O'Keefe former
Mayor Mike Bloomberg kept a low profile
on Friday as his aides turned in
paperwork in Alabama the state with the
earliest filing deadline and there are
plans to do so in other states next week
but would be Democratic opponents
believe Bloomberg should spend its
billions some other way I think it's a
savagely broken system that people who
have wealth can somehow leapfrog others
who might be as viable or more viable
candidates senator Elizabeth Warren
welcomed him to the race by tweeting out
a link to her billionaires calculator
showing what he doe in taxes if she's
president the mayor previously said he'd
stay out of the race because of former
Vice President Joe Biden's commanding
lead over the field but the former veep
who filed his own presidential paperwork
in New Hampshire is falling behind
Warren and Bernie Sanders in some polls
iDEN says Bloomberg needn't worry he's
running because of me I last polls I
looked at and I'm pretty far ahead and
then there's a fellow New Yorker with a
strong opinion president Trump he
doesn't have the magic to do well there
is nobody I'd rather run against than
little Michael that I could do as a
former Republican and independent
Bloomberg would fight for climate change
revamping the nation's schools and gun
control issues that are sure to make him
popular with Democrats but he does face
an uphill climb in a poll just last
month only six percent of likely
Democratic primary voters said they
would definitely vote for the former
mayor if he runs for president for CBS
this morning Saturday at O'Keeffe
Washington